what's going on with with Google and
Amazon and some of the like non-social
media large tech companies in your
opinion yeah so Google is in the middle
so in the book I talk a little bit about
how Google people think Google is this
company that figured out how to do
search and just wrote it to a multi you
know hundred billions of dollars of
valuation and that was it
but Google is this company that's really
gone through so many different
transformations in its history it
started out as a website you would
access on Microsoft's browser Internet
Explorer then it really became a browser
extension on Internet Explorer I don't
know if you know many people remember
but the primary way that people used to
access Google was through Google toolbar
which is an extension you would install
onto Internet Explorer and it would like
show up in the browsers you know Chrome
every Chrome is everything that's not
part of the browsing window and you
would type your searches in and it would
show up in the browser actually more
than 60% of Google search went through
toolbar at a certain time so Google was
an extension then the Google team saw
led by sundar pichai who's now the CEO
of alphabet they saw that Microsoft was
starting to mess with them a little bit
with that toolbar as you might imagine
Microsoft was like we're delivering
billions of dollars to Valley a value to
Google and we all the browser's so why
we continue to do this and so Google
realized that the longer it depended on
Microsoft which was then working on live
search which would become Bing it was
going to be dead and that's when it
really had to build its own browser and
it's funny I remember seeing ads for
Chrome and being like why is Google
building a browser why is the search
engine so intent on the browser but
chrome saved the company and without
building its own successful browser
where you can type your searches in the
address bar you know we might be begging
today like that might be the verb and so
that that's obviously chrome worked out
really well for them so Google's safe
but then we move from desktop to mobile
all of a sudden they need to reinvent
again and they do that using Android
which they acquire and then build up and
then you know we start we start getting
into this mobile world
all of a sudden voice computing happens
and what you do with Google is you ask
it questions you know what time is is
this gonna happen at you know where did
this take place and people start asking
the you know Amazon echo these questions
this is Google's bread and butter so
Google needs to reinvent again and
that's where it started developing the
Google assistant sundar brings the whole
company together and said you puts this
big slide up in front of it in front of
the company and it's all Google's
products and there's like this squiggly
line and it points to assistant and so
the number one thing that we're doing in
this company is turning what we have
into one cohesive assistant the Google
assistant and I think that like this is
gonna be Google's future as whether it
can make that assistant overtake you
know the echo I can't say here let me
pause mute it so I overtake Alexa or you
know it can't lose that and and if
Google if the Google assistant is good
then all of a sudden it propels all the
Google products you use it propels
Android and it propels the Google home
which is still second to the echo but if
you look at the order
you know the echo is it has the lead
then you got Google then there's like an
other category and some are deep inside
that other category which has very few
units sold as Apple's home pod so Apple
is totally letting this revolution slip
by it in terms of Amazon you know
Amazon's like this invention Factory its
culture you know I talked a little bit
about you know working on ideas versus
working on execution and its culture has
you know baked in and like incredible
technology that allow its employees to
focus on invention and that's why
Amazon's been able to go from you know a
online bookseller to a massive first
party marketplace a third party
marketplace logistics and fulfillment
operation a cloud services platform a
voice computing platform a hardware
manufacturer and a grocer and an Academy
Award winning movie studio is because
the company knows how to operate its
processes baked in and we're starting to
see some of the fruits of
you know it's most ambitious AI program
called hands off the wheel and I go into
that in depth in the book hands off the
wheel is a wave that Amazon used machine
learning to automate a good amount of
tasks in its retail organization so its
retail employees were on the phone with
like brands like tide and saying we need
this many detergent units and this many
fulfillment centers you know at this
time for this price and Amazon looked at
itself it was like we got two decades
worth of retail purchase data why are we
having people do this we can just have
software and then slowly but surely over
the last few years they've worked to
automate all these tasks so if you're
tied right now a machine sends you the
purchase order you got an email right
you go and negotiate with a portal the
pricing and promotions are all done with
technology not people used to be a very
big organization inside Amazon and by
freeing those people up the company's
really been able to invent you know
who's next new products my favorite
story is one of this guy
Dilip Kumar who ran pricing and
promotions in the retail organization he
goes and spends like a year and a half
under Bezos taking meetings that he that
Bezos was taking as a technical adviser
by the time he's done pricing and
promotions is totally automated so we
can't go back to this division so he
gets together with a bunch of people
from Amazon's retail organization that
are feeling this place to need to do
something new and they say why don't we
use technology to solve the most
annoying part of shopping in real life
which is checkout and that is the team
that developed Amazon Go which you can
just walk in and take something out and
then it charges you you know there's no
scanning you skin and once with QR code
grab what you want and then walk out it
feels like stealing probably the future
of brick-and-mortar retail period I
think that these systems we're gonna see
in supermarkets all over the place and
and in stores and and I think that
Amazon's really hit on something with
this and it all happened because they
were able to use technology to change
the way they work and make room for more
invention and have the process to invent
so I think that company is you know
really good shape from a business
standpoint the only caveat I'll make
the Amazon is the company needs more
empathy you can tell by the way that
they've engaged in this coronavirus
moment that they they've fired their
whistleblowers they've tried to run a
nasty PR campaign targeting somebody in
their fulfillment center that spoke up
saying he was inarticulate and they
wanted to make him the face of you know
worker resistance and honestly like it's
much easier just to treat your workers
well than to go through all this effort
and the PR campaign to try to make
somebody look bad and I think at a
certain point Amazon needs to realize
that because you know you know consumers
might one day actually say I want to go
to a company that's first priority is
making sure that the people I work for
it it's safe are safe and making sure
that the businesses that sell into it
are sustainable that's good for everyone
and if Amazon doesn't prioritize that
it's going to be in bad shape